there's not much time to say goodbye
here in Saka Russia's Far East most of
these men had only 24 hours notice that
they were being drafted into Russia's
Army
the sum of the 300 000 reservists being
called up to fight in Ukraine
not everyone is going willingly
in Dagestan Russia's southernmost tip
reservists confront a woman at the
military commission what's it for this
war this man shouts
let Putin protect his own palaces not
hide behind our men and children
there are still a few who summon the
courage to protest against President
Vladimir Putin's announcement of a
partial mobilization of civilians this
was in Saint Petersburg
my boyfriend received today a
notification from military commissaryat
so he couldn't come out here but I came
because I don't want our young men to be
taken away
we came to protect our friends our
fathers and our relatives who they want
to take to the war the brutal war
against Ukraine
foreign
monitoring group says at least 1 300
people have been detained in 38 cities
most Russians get their news from State
TV and more than 70 percent of them
definitely or mostly support what Putin
calls a special military operation in
Ukraine
that's according to a poll by an
independent Russian organization before
the draft was announced
the European commission says more than
half a million Russians have left the
country since the invasion began in
February this was the border with
Georgia on Wednesday Finland has also
seen a spike in arrivals
the only remaining direct flights to
European cities are to Istanbul and
Belgrade they're sold out of war is
horrible so uh it's okay to be afraid of
war and of death
sad things but those men who are
eligible for military service will not
be allowed to leave Russia they will
have to stay and fight
and they don't know when they'll see
their families again Bernard Smith Al
Jazeera